let's say that i've got two
chuck norrises or maybe it's chuck nori
and to that i am going to add another
three chuck norrises
so i'm gonna add another three chuck
norrises and this might seem a little
bit obvious but how many chuck norrises
do i now have well two chuck norrises we
can represent this it's literally
a chuck norris plus a chuck norris so
let me do that at chuck norris plus
another chuck norris two chuck norrises
you could also view this two times chuck
norris and this is just another way of
representing it and three chuck norrises
three of chuck norris's you could do
that as a chuck norris
plus a chuck norris
plus another chuck norris
and so we would have a grand total and
this might be
very simple for you but you would have a
grand total of one two three four five
chuck norrises
so this would be equal to this would be
equal to five
chuck norrises now let's get a little
bit more abstract here chuck norris is a
very tangible thing
so let's go to a little bit more of
traditional algebraic notation if i have
two x's
two x's and remember two x this is what
you could do this is two x's or two
times x and to that i would add three
x's
and to that i would add three x's how
many x's do i have
well once again two x's that's two times
x you could view that as an x plus an x
we don't know what the value of x is but
whatever that value is we can add it to
itself and then 3 x's are going to be
that value i'm doing that same green
color
three x's are going to be that value
plus that value plus whatever that value
is and so how many x's do i now have
well i'm going to have 1 2 3 4 5 x's
so 2x plus 3x is equal to is equal to
5x and if you think about it all we
really did and hopefully you
conceptually get it is we just added the
two numbers that we're multiplying the x
and these numbers the two or the three
they're called coefficients very fancy
word but it's just this constant number
this regular number that's multiplied by
the variable you just added the 2 and
the 3 to get your 5x now let's think
about this a little bit more let's go
back to this original expression the two
chuck norris is plus three chuck
norrises let's say to that we were to
add
let's say we were to add some type of a
let's say we were to add seven plums
over here so this is my drawing of a
plum
so we have seven plums plus two chuck
norrises plus three chuck norrises and
let's say that i add another two plums
i add another two plums here so what
would this whole thing be
well i wouldn't add the seven to the two
to the three plus the two we're adding
different things here you have two chuck
norrises and three chuck norrises so
they're still going to simplify to five
chuck norrises and then we would
separately think about the plums we have
seven plums and we're adding another two
plums we're going to have nine plums
plus
nine plums so this simplifies to five
chuck norrises and nine plums similarly
over here if i had instead of just two x
plus three x if i had seven
y
seven y plus two 2x plus 3x plus 2y what
do i now have well i can't add the x's
and the y's they could very well
represent a different number so all i
can do is really add the x's and then i
get the 5x and then i'd separately add
the y if i have seven y's and two that i
add two y's i'm gonna have nine y's if i
have seven of something and i had two of
something i now have nine of that
something so i'm going to have nine y's
so you add that and then a different
color you add
this and this you get that
you add the x's
you add the x's you get that right over
there so hopefully that makes a little
sense actually i'll throw out one more
idea so given this what would happen if
i were to have
two x
plus one
plus seven x
plus five
well once again you might be tempted to
add the two plus the one but they're
adding different things these are two
x's this is just the number one so you
really just have to add the x's together
so you're gonna say well i got two x's
and i'm gonna add seven x's to that well
that means i now have nine x's and then
separately you would say well i've got
just the abstract number one and then i
got another five
one plus five is going to be equal to
six